we really believe and i i myself as well
did the ability to use technology as you
know very well
to make our lives better to make our
lives easier to make certain processes
that we didn't think about exists
[Music]
i'm so happy we're finally doing this
thank you for the time
thank you so much i really appreciate it
this is going to be so much fun and you
know
there's so much that i want to talk
about but first i want to start with
your journey
because you know just going over your
background i got overwhelmed by seeing
the number of different places
and you've gone through you know the
venture capital firms
to productive companies and then back to
venture capital firms across
continents so adi dumb it down for me
how do you get to to to where you are
now at flint capital
and and helping invest you know in in
israel but also previously in new york
talk to me about your journey yeah for
sure um
so i'm american originally i'm actually
from your neck of the woods right now so
i grew up in palo alto parents are
israeli
um moved to israel when i was 12 with
the family
um and basically everything i've done
after the army was either in startups or
in venture capital in some shape or form
i'm a lawyer but i don't practice so i
guess some call it a recovering lawyer
um and yeah i mean i think for you know
i've been in different places because um
i've just been fortunate
basically every time to to get more
exposure more responsibility
um i started off like i said as a lawyer
at one of israel's first billion dollar
internet companies called conduit
i started up there as legal counsel and
then i moved on to manage the compliance
team
and when we when you go to
to study you know law and you go to law
school do you go there you know with the
perception that you want to be
you know a lawyer later on at a tech
company or do you just say okay i want
to be a lawyer because i'm interested in
law
yeah it's a really good question so i
can give you my perspective right
because it's only for my my
point of view but i always i think for
me the way i got to where i
where i am now is based i always think a
few steps ahead so i
i kind of knew in my mind that even
though i liked law and enjoyed it um the
things i liked most were
contract law and business law so i knew
that even if i would join this legal
counsel i always had the
desire to go to the business side at
some point which i think is why i became
legal counsel as my first job as a
lawyer
um and i basically went down that road
right so from legal counsel the company
then i managed a compliance team
which in many ways was a combination of
it was kind of between
law but also a lot of business and also
very technical i managed team of
developers and analysts and
wow the r d teams yeah and then that
time we had
two main clients were google and
microsoft thing so i kind of had to be
the
many ways the bottleneck with regards to
any kind of new product or any kind of
major partnership that we had yeah so it
was pretty
it was pretty cool in that sense what it
sounds to me that you're taking this you
know you're starting out as a lawyer
you're joining a billion dollar company
conduit in israel and you and
then you go and you work with you know
huge clients and
that put you in a position where you're
in the intersection between the tech and
the compliance
and you're getting the exposure both of
the r d but also from your background
and slowly you're moving yourself to the
business and then how do you go to
product and venture capital from there
so first there was i mean venture
capital so i moved on to rhodium from
there which you know also that phil
money he was part of the team and daniel
kanathi obviously in events so i moved
on to there i actually got my first leg
into vc as a student
um at idc at the internet uh
um actually working for what was then
carmel ventures is now viola so i worked
there actually as a student at some
point um
i did like almost 75 of a
position while i was doing two degrees
so that's kind of my first picture in
the world of vc and then
um when i heard from a friend actually
for portfolio company of rhodium
they were looking for somebody to join
the team the investment team was like
okay this is this is where i want to go
i kind of had that
just hunger to enter that space i
thought it was so interesting
i heard about it kind of from my parents
because they were always in tech and
just i was like i need to go down that
route and
um yeah i was really fortunate i think
that a lot of what i went through
in compliance managing teams like you
said and working with r d teams really
helped me then when i met with founders
at rhodium
so so i want you to take me back a
little bit and and give me the pivotal
moments
in your upbringing where you know
because right now you're one of the most
you know popular investors
in israel and no i mean i i've been
recommended to talk to you
on this show from so many people that i
can't even count anymore but
so i'm curious you know what and then
one of the things i'm curious about is
what helps a person
get to where they are today is it you
know just their passion
is it you know opportunities that they
were seizing is it motivation
so what were some of the pivotal moments
that you really became passionate and
you knew
i want to devote myself to to the work
that i'm doing
i think it's a really good question i
mean it's a lot of the things you said
right so first i'm people who know me
i'm a very passionate person i get
very very excited about things that i
believe in sometimes too much
but i'm very very excited about things
i'm passionate about and passionate
about and i think that passion is
something that is contagious
um so that's i think that helps when you
meet people they see that you want
something and you're interested i think
that's help but
in many ways to get to where you want to
go i mean i say this a lot i think you
really need to
be open to meeting people be open to
hearing other people's stories
and learn from their stories what works
for you and what doesn't like i've
always
done my homework before every step i
took whether it was
i moved to new york i had nothing right
like i had nothing i had family and
everything but in new york i had
i didn't come with a partner i had maybe
knew three people i didn't have an
apartment i didn't have a job
but i came very structured and i think
everything i've done was always very
structured like i said i always thought
a few steps ahead so like where do i
want to go and
how do i get there and i think having a
structure and passion
and talking to people and and not being
you know having that great like not
being like shy i was almost seeing
a shame but it's not about being ashamed
it's not being shy
to reach out to people i reached out to
partners really large vc funds in new
york before i moved and said i'm moving
this is my background
i'd love to have coffee and in many
cases it worked and i really believe
that i mean it worked for me then and i
really believe that also today so i hope
that answers your question
it definitely does and my you know
follow-up question is why venture
capital it sounds like you know with
with your passion and consistency you
could choose any job you want in the
world you choose to focus on venture
capital
why do that instead of continuing to
another company or creating your own
company
it's a good it's a good question um i i
love
venture i love this job i love the
ability to
i'm a very curious person so i love the
fact that i get
to meet so many different people and so
many different ideas and learn from them
like my curiosity is
constantly fed on a daily basis which
really intrigues me and i really love
being able to
be helpful and be impactful and i think
that that's a lot of what we do i mean
not every fund does that every investor
does that but i people that know me i
think founders that i that
know me like i try hard to work i work
for them and i think that
um at least i see it that way hopefully
that they will agree but that's how i
kind of view it so
trying to be you know to be helpful and
and i think that
in the end of the day the combination of
a financial
you know a financial business in the end
of the day we are an asset class like
any other in many ways but
being able to bring something that's
beneficial and brings money
but also impacts the world hopefully in
a positive way it makes me feel really
good when it gets me up in the morning
um and of course you know i think that
working for a startup is fantastic and
who knows what you know
what will happen in the future but in
general like i love this job i love
i think for me also i love the fact that
i see different things i've had
opportunities in the past to join
um even when i was in new york like to
join portfolio companies as a ceo and
things like that and i just thought you
know i'll come in and i'll do this it'll
be great but after six months i think
i'll be like okay what's next um not
because it's not interesting but i do
like
touching different things at once that's
just me personally that's so so cool
okay so now you know
talking about journeys and and i'd love
to talk about one of the things that
you're really passionate about
diversity in tech and i think it's you
know on one hand the subject that is
being spoken about more and more
in our domain on the other hand it's
definitely not spoken about enough and
not enough has been done
to to bring that to to level the playing
field and you know as a mother and
you know as an as an ambitious career
woman i'd love to to take
to hear your take on you know what what
where are we at today and what do you
think
needs to happen in order to level the
playing field much more than what is
being done today
so fantastic question so
i think it's it's there is a shift but
it's a little bit i mean it's slow right
i mean
my my point of view has been for a while
is that
if we don't i mean there's some people
that focus on write the top-down
approach okay which is
we need to start from schools we need to
start educating we need to start
even in the form of um you know removing
biases there's this known kind of
um i forgot what type of bias it's
called i think it's the acceptance bias
if i'm not mistaken i don't remember but
you know you're not going to think about
a doctor first as being a female unless
you see many female doctors right
there's something about having that
vision in front of you that helps
children
at the end of the day think that they
can be the next founder the next ceo the
next astronaut et cetera
so some people focus on that and i think
that's really really important
i really believe that in our world it
needs to come top down and i'm not the
only one that thinks this but i've wrote
a few posts about it and i think that
it the problem is is that we don't have
enough people at the top that
trickle down and say okay you know
either i'm a ceo of a fortune 500
or i'm a you know a wealthy individual
or
whatever it may be i have the
opportunity to be impactful and be
helpful
but do i actually do anything to bring
more women to sit next to me and that
just
it's not enough and i think it's
shifting
but i for my mind it's like i just as an
example i started
it's not even like um like a very very
uh organized process but i started
something within there's some
some female investors in in israel a few
funds they started this vc group of
women in vc
and they were like they're 40 something
of us and i said you know there's so
many pitches
pitch events all the time yeah it's a
lot yeah i think for more than 40 now i
think there's near 50 which is fantastic
so that in it of itself shows that there
is a shift
but hold on that i think is great and
because
we've you know i noticed that we have
such amazing power in this platform
let's go and just do pitch events or
office hours some places call it for
female founders and we've been doing it
for a few months now
and it's been fantastic but the reason
why i'm so excited about it is a few
things i think that it's really
important that more female vcs
make decisions because if we're not
making the decisions and we're not part
of the investment committee and we're
not part of
you know actual decisions in check
writing we're not going to get to that
place of being a partner
and then maybe later in you know in the
day becoming an lp ourselves or angel
investor etc so
that's on one hand from the vc side and
then obviously helping the founders
you know female founders who
statistically we know they have a harder
time raising money
have a better opportunity from women
that they usually don't meet
at the table so both sides of that i
think is really crucial but it really
needs to come from the top we need more
lps that are women
we need more cos to be women we just
need more people that
have capital and access and the ability
to make decisions
to start making it for women and not
just women by the way
more any any diversity whether it's in
israel i would say
arabs and and ethiopians and and
whatever it may be
people with disabilities it doesn't
matter just different 100
you know one of the things that i've
been contemplating you know here in
california being in the midst of the
black lives matter movement
one of the things and one of the things
that you know donna means
you know the movement is talking all
about you know not not the fact that the
black lives matter everybody knows that
but it's but it's more specific to that
it's saying that
you know people that are are not
minority that have sort of
what they call you know white privilege
here we have an innate responsibility
not only to not be racist but to
actually take action against it right so
being a bystander is a part of the
problem and i think that what you're
saying here top down and
you know being as a decision maker not
saying that you
are that you're you promote diversity
but the fact that but actually taking
action and
speaking out about that so i think
that's something that's definitely true
but i d
i also want to talk about is a little
bit about investing so you know
coming in i have i'm having the time of
my life with odette phil money at
j ventures and you know as i'm
understanding the world a little bit
better one thing that is very evident
is that you know different places around
the world invest in different ways
and as i get to speak to leaders from
different areas in the world i get to
hear about the different
mindsets you have the unique you know
privilege of seeing both the new york
side and television and i'd love to hear
a little bit about your investment
thesis
and how do you approach opportunities
and what are some of the key questions
that you're thinking about
so just i'll take a little bit of a step
back so in general flint capital is a
global fund so we invest
out of israel but we also invest in the
us and europe um and before that i
worked for
uh two funds in new york that one both
of them were i mean one was actually
kind of global
fintech collective is has a global point
of view and
global thesis on investing in fintech
companies and then symmetrical ventures
we invested
in companies in the us so i've had the
opportunity to invest in startups that
are located in
new york atlanta la silicon valley but
also here in texas so just that's just
in general so i think i have i've been
fortunate to really have a perspective
on different
different ecosystems which i think is
really important right um
what i'll say is this i think that and
this is not just a plug i think this is
something that's really
important about investing is that the
fact that we are as flint capital we
have an opportunity to be here right i'm
the only person here in israel on the
investing team
um but um we have a partner in boston i
think that you know okay so he comes out
here often or before coven he came here
often
um but the ability to be also east coast
and west coast to be
in different ecosystems and have
information from different ecosystems
and being able to see what's happening
get information understand
the different vcs understand the
different leaders is really really
important and i think that that's one
thing
um i would say that investing here is
very different than in the states in in
a few ways i mean i think it's just
what what you know what funds look for
right there is
i'll give you an example and this is
going to be very uh
i mean and this might not sound weird to
you because you know you said like
people out of 8200 and the like
so i think that um in israel there is a
lot of that kind of
which is also not good when we think
about diversity right diversity is not
just about male or female it's about
being different in general so i think
that in israel there's a lot of this
like kind of puppy paste
sometimes where you can find very
talented
individuals that came out of you know
prime minister's office or 8200 or any
one of the other you know 99
any one of these fantastic units and
then they have you know not much
experience very tech based but they're
like this is what i'm doing i can't tell
you what i'm doing but i'm raising money
and then the expectation is for me to be
like i'm in and by the way
many funds will be now i understand
because when you're very smart
technically and you have you know and
you have
so much experience and you're very you
know you can get very far
you can't but i don't think that in the
states you will see so much of that in
general somebody coming out of mit or
carnegie mellon or
the like and being like now we're gonna
throw five you know million dollars
because or i don't know even if you came
out of like an
elite unit in the us army i don't think
that it would be the same
because essentially as you know and i
know i think in the states
and i think also friends who know that
too but it's really really important
to have a really you know the business
acumen
to understand positioning to understand
how you're going to sell your company
and i think that that is a bit of a
difference but on the other hand
the reason why that works in israel is
because it's a small ecosystem and we
know each other and it's easy to get
that
that you know to get the viewpoint on
people understand that they have the
capabilities and then
i think that what's good now is that um
good or bad we can discuss
some people see it differently a lot of
funds you know they have now this kind
of network that they provide to the
founders
right and to help them get to where they
get to go you know where they need to go
it's different it's just very very
different but i think that um
a lot of posit i mean i think that there
is more camaraderie i mean in new york i
was i was super impressed like i think i
loved it that we were sharing
between each other vc's super cool i
don't know if it's like that valley
in new york i i don't know the people
that i met and the funds that i met um
investors we would share information if
i saw something interesting what do you
think about this what are your thoughts
were you looking at it was a lot of
sharing for the sake of working together
and getting feedback especially in the
fintech funds at least i don't know but
not just not just um and i think here
that's happening too but it depends
again which sector some of them are more
like
let's keep it in stealth mode and not
really share um
so i think those are the differences and
i think it's really important for
founders when they think about
you know always think up like what i
said before thinking a few steps ahead
so when you get your seed investor i
would always think about or even your
precede
but think about what you who you want to
be around the table for your a
and what how to get there and i think
that um i think that's really important
i think that you know one of the things
you mentioned so resonated with me
because you know i spent four and a half
years in one of those units in the idf
and then i came here to stanford to
continue my studies and continue
enriching
you know my own my own knowledge both in
engineering but also in business and
scaling products and obviously with joy
ventures
and one of the key distinctions like you
mentioned is i'm saying you know in the
idf we're sitting down we're
doing you know computer science really
really great advanced technology
for many years and then we and then a
lot of my friends go out and and they
build startups
here all of a sudden at stanford you
know the first like the first class we
have is you know
introduction to deep learning the second
class is how to scale your product
it's it's constantly intertwined and
what often
we find though is that and i've talked
to quite a few professors here and they
mentioned that oftentimes
a technion graduate or a graduate of the
unit has more skills than a stanford or
mit graduate which is interesting
but obviously it leads to you know no no
of course i mean that's why that's why
it does work i think that what we get in
the army is you can't get that in many
other places for sure but it's
i think you'll agree with me it's not
the same as exactly as working in a
company and going within
doing an internship at somewhere in the
states i think and i think the best
thing to be able to do this is some
crazy idea i had ones is that we could
get
israelis the opportunity israelis out of
the army the opportunity to work for two
years
at array of fortune 100 companies as a
tech job for two years
learn what it's like to be in these
companies and they can decide if they
want to stay or they want to go and
build their own thing but get
that network get that knowledge and get
the expertise of what it's like to work
in corporate america because that'll be
so beneficial for their next cyber
company or whatever company they'll do
that sounds like it's maybe one thing
that's amazing i can't believe we're
almost at 20 minutes and i would and i
have to spend the last few minutes
understanding
you a little bit better and i'd love to
ask a simple yet difficult question
and what are you passionate about why do
you wake up every morning
and look at deals and do the work that
you do
what what are you really passionate
about right now
so i mean there is the you know what we
do in the fund right i mean
what we invest in you look at companies
that have that are data driven any
company that has some form of cognitive
technology
uh i'm gonna drop the buzzwords but
there is a meaning behind it so we do
like companies that are ai-based nlp
whatever it would be in the world of
cognitive tech but why is that
interesting i
we really believe and i myself as well
did the ability to use technology as you
know very well
to make our lives better to make our
lives easier to make certain processes
that we didn't think about
exist or to take processes that didn't
work and just make them
work better and well and obviously have
a business around it
i personally obviously am excited about
you know those businesses that also have
some
benefit to humanity as well and it
doesn't need to be impact right like
if you're a company that obviously you
know you're helping me with um
you know continue to work at the office
in a very easy secure way okay
that also does good for me but i think
that we're able to
but like for example what passion what i
liked about fintech
specifically is that and i still do is
that there really is a way to invest in
a company that is financially focused
that wants to work within the world of
finance
but you're helping the underbanked the
unbanked emerging markets
you're doing things that you didn't
think you were necessarily doing and
you're making an impact
you didn't think you actually were so to
me that's always very very interesting
and important
um and i think that i mean what gets me
up in the morning like i said is just
being able to
to be a part of that to be able to meet
these individuals there's that moment
when you meet that entrepreneur whether
female male and you're like
holy wow like this is just the right
team i have to invest in this i mean
there's a company right now that i'm
looking at that i hope we close the deal
i can't give too much information
obviously but
they're focusing on such a big important
market that touches each and every one
of us and the technology is super strong
but but you're i mean when i when i will
share with you hopefully and we do
hopefully invest
you're going to hear about it and be
like wow like this is so
it seems so simple but it's so important
and it's so
different and and when you meet
something like that where it's a big big
market
and really really pain and it's not just
a pain to
few people it's a pain to all of us like
in our hearts i think that it's like
you just want to invest you want to be a
part of that journey and be helpful and
and yeah what gets me up also in the
morning is my baby
i love that i love both answers
and you know those deals are rare right
i mean it's you know it's all right
it's not every day that you meet a team
like this and i often
i i i'm good friends here with george
berman from innovation endeavors and
every time i go to their offices and i
look at their board of investments and i
and i asked george like
what are you excited about and he shares
with me the and you're dealing and you
know it's and then to the outsider it
seems that yeah
there's all these amazing amazing deals
that come all the time but it's not true
and i'm seeing it you know j ventures
it's hard to find those deals
they're very rare they're very
competitive but at the end being a
partner on a company that makes a good
impact on the world on a product that
scales and touches
people's lives that's what i'm on my
journey hopefully to do one day
so so look at that hippo was a great
example i mean hippo is yes it's
insurance but you're helping people have
a better
security in their lives and asap bond is
just the best ever
that's a company i wanted to invest in i
i really hear these
sitting here you know one of the things
that i love about kobed and and i hope
he watches this because he's
he's helping sponsor this show is that i
get to sit next to him in an empty
office of 200 people
and i just get to watch him work and you
know while i'm coding away
i'm just listening in by the way he's
one of the people that when
we i met him when he was raising i think
his seed
came to fintech collective and i i told
him this everything he said he would do
he's basically done so unbelievable
three words that you would use to
describe yourself because you already
have a a
meeting with your female vc colleagues
yeah
yeah um wow favorites inspire myself uh
passionate
yes loyal
okay
energetic i guess i love it i love it
passionate loyal energetic adi toda
thank you very very much this is you
thank you so much you're doing such a
great job
and i'm looking forward to maintaining
this relationship and continuing to
learn over the years thank you
thank you